your stomach shrinks if you eat less is
that true
myth jumping or exercising after eating
will give you an appendicitis
what i have never heard of this
i'm tossing that one out ooh so you need
to wait
30 minutes to swim after eating
i caught myself almost saying it to my
own children the other day
and then broke out into laughter because
it's an absolute
myth hi i'm austin chang i'm an
assistant professor of medicine at
jefferson health in philadelphia
and i've been practicing as a
gastroenterologist since 2017.
my name is fola may i'm an assistant
professor of medicine at ucla health i'm
a general gastroenterologist and have
been practicing gastroenterology for the
last six years i love this field because
it allows us to
optimize people's digestive health and
we get to prevent
important cancers like colorectal cancer
and today we'll be debunking myths about
indigestion it takes years to digest
gum this is an absolute myth and i
remember this as a child hearing that it
takes
seven years to digest your gum the
reality is
that everything you eat going in one end
is gonna come out the other the slight
truth of the myth
is that gum is insoluble so we don't
have the enzymes to break down gum like
we do other foods
but it doesn't stay in your stomach for
seven years just like everything else
you eat it gets emptied from the stomach
usually within 30 and 90 minutes
and it comes out in your stool smelly
farts always mean
something is wrong i don't know fulla is
there such a thing as a good smelling
fart
i get this one a lot from my patients so
everyone thinks that if your farts smell
really bad
then there must be something wrong with
the digestive tract
and it's not true some of the most
healthy foods that we eat
like fiber broccoli asparagus
cause the smelliest farts i will say
though that it is important to pay
attention
to whether there are other symptoms
particularly people who have lactose
intolerance which means that they don't
have the enzymes to digest
milk products and if you've noticed
belly farts over and over again
after eating milk products or after
having products like gluten
frequently then it's probably worth
looking into whether you have a food
intolerance or a food allergy the other
symptoms to keep an eye out
for our severe abdominal pain with your
smelly farts
loose stools are diarrhea fevers
this can indicate an abdominal affection
you should be pooping
every day so this is another unfortunate
misconception that human beings have
it can be normal to have a bowel
movement up to three times a day
and there are actually people who are
normal who have bowel movements every
three days
and anywhere in there in between can be
normal what i typically will tell my
patients is that the most
concerning thing is if you are having
infrequent stools that are causing
constipation like symptoms straining a
lot when they're on the toilet bowl
have developed blood in their stools
when they have a bowel movement
and that's generally when we would
prescribe a medication to help you have
more frequent yet gentle bowel movements
the reason why it's important to
sometimes get this checked out by a
professional is because
there are a lot of different causes for
infrequent stools and constipation
and then there's the other end of the
spectrum some people have what we call
inflammatory bowel diseases
these are conditions that cause frequent
stools but also
blood in the stools severe abdominal
pain and bloating
weight loss fatigue other manifestations
throughout the body
and that's concerning so i usually like
to tell people that
it's not the number of the bowel
movements you're having it's whether or
not there are any of these concerning
symptoms myth or fact
only spicy foods cause ulcers
if this were true i'd be very sad
because
i love spicy food and i eat spicy food
all the time spicy food does not cause
ulcers but that doesn't mean that spicy
food doesn't cause pain
what does cause ulcers can be a bacteria
called h pylori that can live under the
surface of the lining of the stomach
and this can cause ulcers as well as
certain medications
like nsaids which are basically those
over-the-counter pain medications like
motrin advil
we want to be careful when we're taking
medications like that stress typically
does not cause
ulcers although it may make existing
ulcers
worse there are certain conditions that
are called
stress ulcers but this really applies to
people who are very very sick
like hospitalized sick and not the
typical type of stress that we think of
when we're stressed out
i think that is a common myth though
austin right i mean you hear people say
all the time
i'm so stressed i'm going to get an
ulcer when i was younger i would just
listen to that statement and now i kind
of want to interrupt and say
no actually that's not how it works
exactly but doesn't mean that stress
doesn't trigger like belly pain because
you know stress can certainly exacerbate
and worsen those types of symptoms
but yeah in and of itself it's not going
to cause an ulcer to just form out of
nowhere
thank goodness right yeah we'd be seeing
a lot more ulcers then
your stomach shrinks if you eat less is
that true
myth this is part of what people think
they can do to control their weight
there's this misconception that
if you eat less your stomach will become
smaller and then you won't need as much
food
to survive and live your daily life
unfortunately it is very
false the size of the adult stomach
stays
approximately that size your entire life
the stomach is actually a pretty
flexible organ so it does
expand when we eat big meals but then it
goes right back to its normal size
when the stomach empties itself about 30
90 120 minutes later
naturally our stomachs won't shrink but
there are procedures out there where we
can actually reduce the volume of the
stomach and then
help patients to lose weight that way
but that requires a procedure
good analogy is probably a rubber band
right so rubber band has a defined
size and you can stretch it out if you
have a big meal
and it will always go back to that size
and it's not until you're
really pushing the limits over and over
again that it starts to develop those
little breaks
get a little bit wobbly and larger but
generally it has its innate size
jumping or exercising after eating will
give you appendicitis
what i have never heard of this
i'm tossing that one out i have my
handy-dandy plushie here
the appendix is this pocket that comes
off of the beginning of the colon
sometimes it can get inflamed or blocked
off and that's called appendicitis
but exercising or jumping around after
eating
no and we would be seeing people
dropping like flies
at the gym if that were the case first
of all that thing is really cute
and second of all i agree completely can
you imagine all the athletes that would
be developing
depend assignments and most of the time
it just comes about
there's nothing that sort of leads up to
it just suddenly happens
and luckily appendicitis is something
that's very treatable
oh so you need to wait 30 minutes to
swim
after eating so this is the hog wash
that every parent has told
every child the reality is after you
have a large meal
your body does shunt a blood flow to
your stomach
and your digestive organs to help you
digest this meal and i think what's
happened is that people have then
feared that because it's shunting blood
away from your arms and your legs and
the large muscles that you need to swim
but if you immediately jump into a pool
you won't be able to swim
or use your arms and legs to save
yourself but the reality is
your body has enough blood flow to
supply both your stomach
and your digestive organs and your legs
and arms there are some people that will
experience some abdominal cramping
if they swim immediately after eating a
big meal
and that's just because the digestive
muscles are already
busy at work and you're stressing them
more by putting them under the exertion
of being in a swimming pool
but i don't think we need to worry about
drowning risk here
probiotics will fix your gut we wouldn't
have jobs
if probiotics cured everything about the
gut
i think what the statement is trying to
get at is that there's a lot about the
gut microbiome the bacteria that live in
our gut
that can potentially impact our health
we simply just don't know enough about
it there is an
actual bacterial environment that lives
in your gut
most of them are not bad bacteria
they're good healthy bacteria that you
need to have normal bowel movements to
avoid
pain and other diseases but every once
in a while that can get imbalanced
so probiotics became really popular with
this concept of resetting
your microbiome but the reality is that
the science is so
new in this area and there's really very
few conditions where we figured out
how to use probiotics the right way and
part of the reason behind this is
because
there's very little regulation on
probiotics by the fda for instance
there's very little consistency in the
formulations
we don't know what dosage actually works
for certain conditions as well
so there's still a lot that we don't
know about probiotics
i do think that for some people it has
an impact but
it's not a cure-all and it doesn't work
for everyone oh
good one i got food poisoning from the
last thing
i ate in reality it takes hours right
for your stomach and your small bowel to
process each meal
so it's usually the second to last thing
you ate
and i think there's a big misconception
about this because
patients will come in and swear that it
was the breakfast they ate and i
tend to ask them actually would you have
dinner the night before
or if they're saying that they developed
their symptoms in the evening it's what
did you have at breakfast because that
might be the culprit
how bad is that word by the way food
poisoning i know who came up with that
because it's not the food itself that's
causing the poisoning right the
definition
of food poisoning first of all is very
broad it can involve
different types of bacteria the toxins
that they create it can involve
viruses the key things are to
rest and to try and stay hydrated you
want to start with
one or two bland items and small bites
of that to see if
you tolerate it and then in a few hours
maybe a few more bites
the last thing you want to reincorporate
to your diet after a bad bout of food
poisoning
are lactose products because the lactate
enzymes
that line your intestines are some of
the last enzymes to come back
and to repopulate so you're really not
prepared to digest
lactose containing foods for a while
what
women don't need regular colonoscopies
is that what it says i'm going to rip
this one up
this one is absolutely a meth
this is your colon unfortunately
a reasonable percentage of us will grow
what we call
polyps in your colon they look like
pimples but the dangerous thing is that
a
small percentage of them over years and
years and years can develop into colon
or rectal cancer
because unfortunately there's been this
myth that colorectal cancer
only occurs in men it's important for
women to know
that colorectal cancer occurs in women
as well
it follows just lung and breast cancer
and being the most common cancers for
women
and unfortunately it's the third most
common cause of cancer-related deaths
in women so all you women out there get
your colonoscopies
everyone who is average risk for
colorectal cancer meaning that you don't
have a family history
and meaning that you don't have a
predisposing condition for colorectal
cancer
should start screening at age 45 or 50.
i feel really bloated
so it must be ibs to have a diagnosis of
irritable bowel syndrome
or ibs you actually have to meet define
criteria that have to do with your bowel
movements and
pain but bloating itself
doesn't necessarily mean that you have
irritable bowel syndrome
bloating is so common having some
bloating here or there is totally normal
that's normal fluctuations depending on
what we eat
it's usually related to what we're
putting into our bodies
fiber which we know is very helpful and
very
healthy can cause increased bloating
there are other conditions that can also
cause
bloating including bacterial overgrowth
or certain intolerances like lactose
intolerance and actually there's
set criteria in how we define
what ibs or irritable bowel syndrome is
and bloating isn't technically part of
that definition it more
depends on kind of the appearance or the
form of the stool the frequency of the
stool
but not necessarily bloating per se i
just know
i have a gluten allergy oh this is also
a very good one
because everybody thinks that they have
a gluten allergy
and oftentimes it's not true
it's really important to distinguish
between celiac disease
which is an autoimmune disease that
doesn't allow you to digest
gluten from non-celiac
gluten sensitivity and those are the two
most common things that people are
confusing when they talk about gluten
allergy so let's talk about
celiac disease first it impacts the
lining of your small bowel
and it makes it impossible for you to
tolerate or digest
gluten but to have a formal diagnosis
with this autoimmune condition you need
to have testing
the other thing we've seen recently
though is that there are many people
that don't have a positive celiac test
but still have some symptoms when they
have
food with gluten so we don't want people
to be on a celiac diet unless they
really have celiac disease we want
people to get
the nutrition that their particular body
needs to function and process normally
and unfortunately we have such a problem
in this country with inappropriate diets
that people were putting themselves at
harm
when you're hearing bold health claims
online
double triple check reach out to
your doctors to ask whether or not what
you're reading is true if there's any
science behind
it look at the science yourself just
keep asking questions
we're always happy to answer those
questions and help out in
whichever way we can the way that i
think about it everyone wants to be able
to eat
comfortably and to be able to poop we
give people that power
to enjoy their food to feel comfortable
without abdominal symptoms
and to go on enjoying their